>> Tucker: MR. FRANKS,
THANKS FOR JOINING US, I
APPRECIATE IT?
>> Tucker: LAST WEEK WE HAD
DAVE PORTMAN ON BAR STOOL
SPORTS STOOL A T-SHIRT HE
CAME UP.
AT THE TIME THE GIRDING FOR
A LAWSUIT.
BUT THEY HAVE THANKFULLY
BACKED DOWN IN THE POWERFUL
FACE OF DAVE WHO JOINS TO US
CELEBRATE HIS VICTORY
AGAINST THE MEGA LIFT THE
NFL.
HOW DID YOU WIN?
HOW DID YOU BEAT THE NFL?
NOBODY DOES THAT.
>> I DON'T REALLY KNOW.
I FOUND OUT AS I WAS WALKING
OUT OF THE OFFICE, I THINK,
THURSDAY THAT THEY
SUBMITTED.
I WOULD USE THE ANALOGY WE
SAID EITHER PICK UP A SWORD
AND FIGHT OR ROLL OVER AND
LET US PET YOUR BELLY LIKE
AUTO DOG AND GOODELL ROLLED
OVER AND WE ARE PETTING HIS
BELLY, LEGS GOING.
I DON'T HAVE THE RECIPE BUT
THEY ROLLED OVER SO IT'S
GREAT.
>> Tucker: BASICALLY THEY
SPORTS.
>> I THINK SAID WE DIDN'T
ROLLED OVER.
>> Tucker: GOOD FOR YOU.
GOOD TO SEE JUSTICE PREVAIL.
THE NFL IS IN A TOUGH SPOT.
LOST A TON OF VIEWERS AND I
THINK THEY ARE WORRIED IT'S
FAIR TO SAY.
YOU FOLLOW THIS FOR A
LIVING, WHY DO YOU THINK
THAT IS?
WHAT'S THE CORE PROBLEM IN
THE NFL?
>> WELL, I THINK IT'S A
COMBINATION OF THINGS MOSTLY
I THINK THERE IS MORE
COMPETITION.
THERE ARE SO MANY DIFFERENT
WAYS TO VIEW DIFFERENT
WHETHER IT BE SPORTS,
ENTERTAINMENT CHANNELS THE
INTERNET.
DOING A GREAT JOB WITH IT.
HE HAS LOST TOUCH, GOODELL
HAS, WITH THE GENERAL
PEOPLE.
ALL THOSE FACTS COMING
TOGETHER.
COMPETITION NUMBER ONE.
PLACES LIKE US THAT THEY CAN
CONSUME CONTENT A MILLION
DIFFERENT WAYS IT'S HARD TO
KEEP ATTENTION SPANS.
>> Tucker: DO YOU THINK
TAKING ATTENTION AGAINST THE
FAMED NEW ENGLAND FOOTBALL
FRANCHISE MIGHT HAVE HURT
THE NFL IN THE END WHEN YOU
MESS WITH TOM BRADY, DO YOU
THINK THEIR CAR MICK
CONSEQUENCES TO THAT?
I MEAN ANY TIME THEY MESS
WITH BASICALLY A -- YOU RUN
THE RISK OF RUNNING INTO THE
REPERCUSSIONS.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED.
>> Tucker: SO YOU TRIED TO
WORN
>> Tucker: DO YOU THINK THEY
REGRET NOT LISTENING TO YOU,
BAWFERLS I THINK YOU RAISED
THIS YEARS AGO WHEN YOU SAID
YOU GUYS ARE
YOU GUYS RRE
YOU GUYS RAIDERS OF THE LOST
ARC.
THE STONE.
HAVE THEY PAID ATTENTION TO
YOUR WISDOM.
>> THEY HAVEN'T TO THIS
POINT I THINK ROGER GOODELL
REFUSES TO EXIST
REFUSES TO AXIST
REFUSES TO ADMST
REFUSES TO ADMIT THAT WE
EXIST.
WEE HAVE GONE TO JAIL.
LAST TIME WE CHECKED HE SAID
HE HAS NOT HEARD OF US.
HE HAS NOT APOLOGIZED
FORMALLY BUT WE AWAIT THAT.
>> Tucker: I HEARD YOU HAD A
BEESTING TODAY.
>> MAJOR BEESTING.
LAYING AT THE POOL IN MIAMI
AND WAS I JUST RELAXING AND
NEXTENING I KNEW I WAS STUNG
BY A BE.
MY FINGER BLEW UP.
I'M HERE AND IT'S 9:00 ON A
FRIDAY AND THAT SPEAKS TO MY
WORK ETHIC.
>> Tucker: ALMOST LIKE A
MAILMAN IT DOESN'T MATTER
WHAT NATURE THROWS AT YOU
BULL FORWARD.
>> THE MAIL THEN THROUGH.
THIS AGAIN, YOU KNOW, I'M
NOT GOING TO DISPARAGE THE
MAILMAN.
I KNOW I'M HERE.
DID I MY JOB TO QUOTE BELL
BELICHICK.
I'M IN MIAMI ON VACATION AND
I'M PUNCHING THAT CLOCK